en el mundo existen dos clases de
personas las que se tiran al precipicio
con alas y las que construyen sus alas
mientras van cayendo hace tres años con
esta frase entendí muchas de las cosas
que me acaban de pasar incluso si
alguien me dice mucho de lo que me va a
pasar seguramente no se lo cree o no
hago nada al respecto no lo sé
con esta frase entendí que valía la pena
dar un salto de fe uno que incluso ya
había dado sin darme cuenta yo lleva
construyendo mis alas mientras caía y
sigo
el miedo y el dolor nos paralizan
cuantas veces por miedo o por dolor no
actuamos
el miedo al éxito el miedo al fracaso
para mí siempre han sido un motor para
el hacia donde yo quiera miedo en el
dolor son un motor que nos paralizan
nos alejan o nos hacen actuar hay un
dicho que me encanta que dice que en mi
miedo y en mi dolor mando yo
cuando vas a ser papá pensarías que le
tienes que contar a tus hijos sobre el
mundo a mí me pasó lo contrario con un
diagnóstico un diagnóstico que estamos
acostumbrados a que condena y etiqueta o
que inhabilita socialmente que
condiciona tu vida y tu día a día
un diagnóstico que incluso algún
especialista te dice lo que se cree que
no va a poder hacer para que entonces ni
siquiera lo intentemos en el 2012
escuché por primera vez las palabras tu
hijo tiene autismo y lo que conllevan
esas palabras
ante la falta de conocimiento la falta
de información los paradigmas y los
tabús sociales me acuerdo perfectamente
en donde estaba a lo que el lienzo el
consultorio por sólo esperen
experiencias que te marcan de por vida
y recibir comentarios como no le digas a
nadie te lo van a etiquetar o un
especialista que te dice ánimo y ya
ánimo es lo tengo pero qué hacemos con
un simple diagnóstico puede etiquetar o
condenar a alguien y entonces te
paraliza por el miedo
en nuestro caso empezamos a actuar lo
mejor que podíamos con lo que teníamos
pero lo que no nos acostumbramos fue a
no poder tener una vida típica porque ir
al cine ir al súper ir a un restaurante
una fiesta infantil se podría convertir
en una de las peores experiencias que
podíamos vivir y en la mayoría de los
casos sólo por el entorno que es un día
mi suegra lleva al súper a mi hijo y
quería unas papas y como buenos
pensadores concretos las papas las
quería justo en ese momento y grito y
una señora se acercó y le dijo ese niño
necesito una nalgada y mi suegra le dijo
la nalgada la necesito a usted el tiene
autismo
lo suyo es ignorancia
meses después me dijeron una frase que
me marcó que me dijeron es que el
autismo no le interesa a nadie
en el 2013 viví mi primer 2 de abril
qué es el día mundial de concientización
del autismo
y yo esperaba algo más esperaba no sé
más herramientas mayor visibilidad más
algo que me empoderar a algún movimiento
o no sé algo aún habiendo centros
terapéuticos con años de experiencia a
mí me hacía falta eso
y aunque parezca poco vi esto que forma
parte de un movimiento internacional de
iluminar de azul edificios emblemáticos
por todo el mundo porque estado producto
sin speaks y a mí me dio esperanza me
sentí menos solo había algo mucho más
allá que tan sólo la palabra autismo
pero la gente no sabía por qué
me di cuenta que estábamos haciendo poco
porque el autismo interesada en los
medios de comunicación sólo escuche hoy
se conmemora el internacional de
concientización del autismo
escuché a un neurólogo explicando la
parte científica o la parte clínica del
autismo que ya he escuchado incluso dos
veces y la verdad es que había entendido
muy poco
hacía falta algo más a mí me hacía falta
algo más el contenido era corto no era
relevante y no era coloquial
en el 2013 vivió una experiencia en
donde de esas que acumulamos los padres
que vamos por la vida acumulando con un
escudo y una espada y de repente estamos
en el aeropuerto nos íbamos a subir un
avión para un viaje familiar estábamos
en el gusano del avión y de repente
álvaro veníamos emocionado y gritó el
tipo de enfrente no le gustó el grito al
segundo grito el tipo se volteó con cara
de peores amigos me disculpé al tercer
grito ya se imaginarán me dieron ganas
de empujarlo dieron ganas de golpearlo
dieron ganas de decirle si supieras que
tiene autismo tu jeta sería diferente o
incluso puede haber sido un poco más
amable y decirle tiene autismo no pasa
nada pero la verdad la verdad es que me
paralicé por el miedo por el dolor por
la acumulación no lo sé pero me paralicé
y ante la frustración de no poder hacer
nada al respecto de no haber sido capaz
de actuar lo único que pude pensar
cuando me subí a el avión fue si por mi
cuenta cabe el 2 de abril lo vuelve a
hacer igual
cómo
no lo sé pero esto yo no lo vuelvo a
vivir
en el 2014 e inicie un evento de una
campaña de concientización alrededor del
evento con un éxito que francamente yo
no me esperaba
y se empezó a hacer una bolita de nieve
me empezaron a preguntar y qué más vas a
hacer y la verdad es que yo no tenía ni
idea en el 2015 en un alineamiento
impresionante de los astros y con el
apoyo de varias personas pudimos hacer
una campaña con el fútbol como eje
cuando nos dimos cuenta teníamos a más
de 100 futbolistas internacionales y
nacionales un vídeo con 23 estrellas de
fútbol internacionales e incluso 6
campeones del mundo vídeos o spots en
televisión nacional con la selección
mexicana y la bolita de nieve se
convirtió en una avalancha
por azares del destino y en una serie de
circunstancias afortunadas acabe ese
mismo año dando y dando un discurso en
palacio nacional frente al presidente en
la firma de la ley de general de autismo
en nuestro país
salí del palacio nacional me paré en la
plancha del zócalo y sólo pude pensar
que alguien me expliqué lo que acaba de
pasar con mi vida en 60 días
a finales de febrero estábamos
presentando una idea me había convertido
en vocero de la causa y estaba
terminando de dar un discurso en palacio
nacional frente al presidente en la
firma de una ley al nombre de cientos de
miles de familias y de cientos de
organizaciones con una gran
responsabilidad
llega a mi oficina
en ese entonces trabajaba y llega mi
jefe y me dice está increíble lo que
estás haciendo pero llevas casi mes y
medio sin pararte en la oficina
y entonces me tira al precipicio y me
salto de fe y renuncia a mi trabajo
renuncia a mi trabajo para dirigir
iluminemos de azul como una organización
sin fines de lucro con un propósito con
un emprendimiento social y con cuatro
objetivos visibilizar el autismo generar
un interés público sumar voluntades y
provocar un cambio radical en el entorno
incluso
me di cuenta que no se trataba sólo del
2 de abril ni siquiera del mes sino de
todos los días me di cuenta que con
esperanza y empoderamiento éramos
capaces de hacer lo que no nos
imaginábamos
incluso cuando me preguntan de repente
es una anécdota personal cuando me
preguntan cómo lo hiciste y demás me
acuerdo de un chiste de ese que había
tres albercas una de cocodrilos una de
pirañas y una de tiburones y en un
concurso bien que atravesaba a las tres
y después de varios intentos y varios
comidos por fin un tipo logra atravesar
las tres cuando sale del última alberca
totalmente agotado llegan los medios de
comunicación y le preguntan cómo le hizo
y lo único que puede decir es quién fue
el hijo de que me empujó
históricamente hemos visto la
discapacidad como lastimó como tragedia
clasificamos a las personas con autismo
con alguna condición de vida como grupo
vulnerable nos convertimos en objetos de
caridad o de inspiración
como sociedad estamos acostumbrados al a
mí quien me puede ayudar como si
esperáramos que bajar el chapulín
colorado' a resolver nuestros problemas
nos hemos convertido en una sociedad que
se queja y hace poco hemos hecho de la
que el deporte nacional y actuamos poco
ahora bien hoy sabemos que uno de cada
115 niños tiene autismo
el autismo es una condición invisible
como vamos a incluir lo que desconocemos
las causas por encima de conceptos
necesitan símbolos y colores para ser
representadas pero resulta también
el diagnóstico puede ser evolutivo
nosotros pasamos de un
trastornos de un trastorno generalizado
del desarrollo a un espectro autista a
un x fracc
si la palabra autismo da miedo
imagínense x frágil
yo digo que suena de entrada al nombre
de nave de star wars y de los malos
el x frágil es la principal causa de
discapacidad intelectual y asociada al
autismo
y resulta que puede ser leve moderada o
severa hoy entiendo y hoy lo que
entiendo yo es que la discapacidad es un
concepto en permanente evolución y que
nos hace falta muchísimo por entender
del tema
como colectivo
clasificamos conceptos etiquetas o
filosofías trastorno condición espectro
síndrome discapacidad
cuando no nos damos cuenta que la
necesidad es exactamente la misma
e inclusión
y para que eso suceda solo hace falta
comprender ernesto reaño psicólogo y
lingüista de perú en una en un libro
reciente recientemente publicado escribe
que clasificamos la discapacidad como si
ésta no dependiera del entorno o de las
circunstancias en donde se nace o se
vive y piense
puede ser muy relativo
la inclusión es un derecho no un favor
ni siquiera deberíamos estarlo
planteando
de qué se trata
de respetar los derechos las capacidades
los talentos fomentar la dignidad
competitiva
imagínense una persona con una maestría
en la mejor universidad de méxico lo
ponemos a sacar fotocopias porque
pobrecito tiene gripa
un nuevo paradigma para la educación
han sido capaces de aprender o no hemos
sido capaces de enseñarles nosotros
porque lo que no nos damos cuenta es que
el principal reto para cualquier
discapacidad condición está en el
entorno
y no hace falta un entorno que resuelva
pero sí que facilite nada más
hoy podemos ver en medios masivos las
principales causas del autismo los
estigmas o los paradigmas creados
alrededor del tema
el uso peyorativo de la palabra de burla
pero ese no es el problema el problema
es que no estamos preparados como
sociedad para entender la diversidad
como algo normal
que nos humaniza y que nos enriquece
porque piénselo quién gana o quién se
favorece de un programa de inclusión en
el trabajo o en la escuela el entorno
todos los demás
hemos entendido la diversidad de razas
estamos entendiendo la diversidad de
género y tarde o temprano entenderemos
la diversidad neurológica
la inclusión no es física cuántica
sin ser físico ni matemático
desarrolle esta fórmula que por más
compleja que pueda parecer en realidad
es muy sencilla sólo hace falta
comprensión empatía respeto con ajustes
y apoyos para que se dé la inclusión y
creo que todos coincidiremos con que al
mundo hoy le vende un poquito bien
poquito de todo esto de la inclusión nos
beneficiamos todos
les voy a contar una anécdota de que si
alguien hubiera tenido hace cinco o diez
años una idea vamos a organizar un
partido de fútbol de personas o chavos
con síndrome de down y los vamos a poner
a jugar fútbol contra niños con autismo
que hubieran pensado estoy seguro que de
locos no nos baja incluso nosotros
cuando planteamos la ya dijimos y como
le vamos a hacer y la respuesta fue ya
veremos y la pregunta fue por qué no
porque sólo bastaba irnos a la
posibilidad para darnos cuenta que
podemos hacer grandes cosas el 2 de
abril lo realizamos invitamos a 35 niños
con síndrome de dawn a jugar contra 35
niños con autismo en un cuadrangular
amistoso de fútbol
y si nos faltaron los autogoles como
cualquier parte de fútbol
no faltó quien agarró la pelota y salió
corriendo para el otro lado no faltó
quien se puso a jugar con el pasto
porque le importaba más el pasto que la
propia pelota pero fue una experiencia
espectacular en todos los sentidos para
los papás
para los terapeutas para los profesores
de fútbol para todos los voluntarios
para todos los que estábamos ahí
presentes y que creen también para los
niños porque solo los pusimos a jugar
fútbol
no nos damos cuenta de que el primer la
primera barrera para la inclusión son
nuestros propios miedos
ahora como papá una de los de los
comentarios que me pueden hacer
qué padre qué increíble lo que haces por
tuyo el amor por tu hijo lo que te
llevado a hacer pero el amor por mi hijo
esté implícito él no tiene la culpa de
que su papá es un tipo inquieto porque
yo no lo hago por él lo hago por mí yo
no sé si seremos capaces de corregir
ciertas conductas socialmente no
aceptadas derivadas del autismo pero lo
que sí sé que podemos ser capaces de
cambiar la percepción de como el mundo
del autismo porque lo que no nos damos
cuenta es que está en cada uno de
nosotros hacer una diferencia lo dijo
john es que él
una persona puede hacer la diferencia
así que todos deberían de intentarlo
yo tampoco quiero ser objeto ni de
calidad ni de lástima ni de inspiración
tener un hijo con autismo no me
convierte en un papá especial tener
hijos me convierte en papá y punto nada
más
hasta que a mí me digan que no se puede
para que por lo menos lo intente fui
torero hace casi 20 años y para mí
siempre se trató de una manera de
entender y de afrontar la vida del toro
aprendí empujar mis límites afrontar mis
miedos por elección propia y de manera
constante aprendí a dar lo mejor de mí
con lo que tenga enfrente hacer lo que
toca lo mejor que puedo que de eso se
trata la vida
y les comparto esta frase que le ha dado
sentido a todo
iluminemos de azul me dio un trabajo con
propósito
pero esta frase claro sentido a todo
pensé que tendría que enseñar a mi hijo
sobre el mundo resulta que le tengo que
enseñar al mundo sobre mi hijo
y solo puedo agregar y volviendo a la
pregunta obligada odiar el autismo cómo
puedo odiar lo que ha sacado lo mejor de
mí
[Aplausos]